this is an Army on a roll the ukrainians
are taking advantage of Russia's
faltering military and now they have the
city of keson in their sights
the road in is scarred and littered with
the debris from months of brutal
fighting we pass a Russian army truck
which has been destroyed but you can
still see the cargo of looted goods
as the artillery team reaches the launch
site about 20 kilometers from the port
the soldiers quickly spring into action
of course as he said CM as the Russians
withdraw the ukrainians are continuing
to engage them with barrages of
artillery they are unclear what the
retreat means and how quickly it will
happen
they are keeping up the pressure after
Russia's defense minister announced the
kremlin's forces were falling back to
the other side of the danipro river it
is a significant defeat
it's estimated there could be thousands
of Russian soldiers still on the West
Bank potentially trapped
here shallow dugouts by the side of the
road have now been deserted
Ukrainian Firepower has pushed them out
of this area our tour whose parents are
still trapped in occupied Kirsten City
hopes it will not be long before they
are reunited uh
Ukrainian progress has been stymied by
mines and bridges that have been blown
but they are winning here on the
southern front
this video shows soldiers in newly
liberated sneer harivka the national
flag proudly on display
even as new places are freed they're
still trying to comprehend the full
horror of Russia's occupation
Vladimir shows me where he buried his
uncle Ukrainian war crimes investigators
have now exhumed the bodies he tells me
he was shot multiple times by Russian
soldiers
there are so many stories like this the
pathologist this morgue says widespread
evidence of war crimes is clearly
and as more places are liberated it's
expected more atrocities will be
uncovered but there is still a long way
to go in this fight even though Victory
here may not be far away
Alex Rossi Sky News in cairson region